[Musik]
heute bin ich bei dem blog blog st so
haben sie mich ganz stark schon
vergessen
na ja das war die happy bleibt genau wir
werden jetzt hier die rückfahrt einmal
ändern haben wir uns nie zu groß aber
die kamera gerade auch in den videos
weil man sieht halt immer nur diese
bereiche und wenn man jetzt eine küche
steht privat ist das gar kein problem
aber wenn meine videos immer die gleiche
mitte gehört immer grau in grau
das wird glaube ich ein so schöner
kammer sorgt hier ist gerade außerhalb
von der kirche und die schau jetzt ganz
normal an das ich so mache weil
irgendwann muss ich erst lernen nun eine
chance haben würde es mich gerettet und
mir im kino ich in altach stelle
liegende tat ja wenn man ja das ist so
das ist ein typisch kiki ist schwer so
ist wir müssen also eine woche mit der
verbringt ist sie genau das ist mein
alter also der markus doch wirklich da
und mit dem mannschafts sich aber dafür
kommen gewinn und werden
also könnte markus kommt
[Musik]
trotzdem setzte einmal ein wort markus
ich muss doch kommen
also ich würde echt toll wie du es
machst du nicht ordentlich ja dass ich
mal gezeigt dass ich vertrauen kauf wie
name ist sie jetzt in einem gesicht
richtig lecker heute müssen freiwillig
erfolgen
was ist da er ist eine leckere da ja
nämlich asche war diese schwarze möchte
ich mal richtig so kam ähnlich süß
persönlich vielleicht wird braucht
vielleicht drin nicht wieder aber dafür
sagt ich überhört ich genau diese sehr
sehr sehr gesund sein
jetzt geht es weiter her einschätzt
übertreiben annehmen
naja hinstellen auf dem tisch und es
wird also die trompete liebling
jeweiligen dinge kommentierte das ist
benutzen sie nicht beweisen oder so vor
alkohol das beziehe ich benutze nämlich
für auszuspielen so ich glaube du merkst
du ich kann mir nicht helfen aber ich
weiß was ich gut kann kaffee und lea
nichts mehr drin sind schon traurig dass
gute arbeit geleistet aber das was neues
kommt den kaffee genießen
jetzt warte ich nur noch auf die anderen
und dann kann die küchen montage
beginnen dort ich bin so gespannt wie es
aussehen wird
[Musik]
graf so schnell gehen dass sich ist weg
diese bei markus s
wie geht es dir heute gut ich habe nur
kuchen erwartet jungen zu leider nicht
voll auf den falschen brüste geschmack
in kuchen da als york aus
diesmal aber dann weil wir dann im
küchenstudio allem an das thema fragt
immer schon mal wissen
auf jeden fall um den kann man nur
schwer durchschauen dass ein bisschen
mal kommt und den komfort einer
steckdose steckt ja alles noch zu teuer
oder unterschied schon jetzt gibt's
richtig lecker
[Musik]
ja okay was meine position auf einem
autohof was ist los
wir fahren jetzt ganz schnell dennoch 40
minuten dann machen wir leben nicht weil
es im sitz listen wirklich auch so
kurzer blitzen drücker
ja wir brauchen deko für die küche soll
er aussehen
[Musik]
wir kaufen nicht ganz schnell den
letzten zwanzig immer typisch wir ne
letzten 20 minuten deko kaufen wisst ihr
warum geboren musste ich morgen ein
video drehen und das sieht ein bisschen
leer aus aktuell noch
[Musik]
also es wochenendes jetzt ruhen und
heute kommt der bernhard und macht uns
die ganzen offen und regale hin dass das
ding ist die rückwand musste erstmal in
ruhe trocknen eigentlich zwölf stunden
da kam das wochenende dazwischen schnell
damit seid nicht so leer aussieht
irgendwas ganz hohes gesucht weil ja da
muss einfach dass sie einfach zu leer
aus aber heute komme wie gesagt diese
ganzen industrie style regale dahin und
ich glaube das wird dann auch noch mal
ganz anders aus
das ist kein zeitraffer
[Musik]
richtige asi weil ich hier auf die
schweißnaht ich mich so gar nicht dem
[Applaus]
anderen
irgendwie aufpassen wenn sie wissen
[Musik]
so zum ende des videos hier nochmal der
hinweis dass hier ist keine bezahlte
kooperation das muss man vielleicht auch
auf youtube noch mal dazu sagen weil
sonst wird immer noch von ausgegangen
okay das ist direkte kooperations
videomarkt das entsteht aus freiwilligen
stücken einfach weil ich euch mitnehmen
wollte und viele von euch kennen den
markus eigentlich schon durch uns quasi
familie man nach führt ja war ihre
küchen in bochum da haben wir auch die
ganze küche her und da habe ich gesagt
hey komm lass uns das doch mal machen
ich bestelle jetzt bei euch meine
rückwand und dann haben wir noch das
schöne warme holz was ich hier sowieso
überall in der küche so ein bisschen
habe ich jetzt der kräuterkasten
realität auf jeden fall werde ich euch
seine seite natürlich in die infobox
verlinken aber dennoch sei gesagt dass
es hier keine kein werbe video also sind
die trikots freiwilligen stücken und
jetzt bin ich gespannt was ihr zum make
over dieser küche sagt hat sich vorher
besser gefallen
gefällt euch jetzt besser was will dir
noch verändern oder meint ihr das ist
jetzt so verkommen bei mich wenn ihr
meinen kann man natürlich kostenlos
abonniert dann verpasste eben meine
videos auch nicht mehr
bis jetzt habe ich nur eine hand reif
für eine verabschiedung tschüs loki der
hammer ruf 1000 schlafzimmer
[Musik]